[Música]
y
en cubo empieza a acceder el incendio en
un depósito de combustible de matanzas
que en cinco días destruyó el 40 por
ciento de las instalaciones que proveen
de electricidad a la isla los
trabajadores de emergencia ahora
intentarán acceder al sitio de la
explosión causada por un rayo para
evaluar los daños
el ministro de defensa de venezuela
vladimir padrino lópez informó que
buscará restablecer las relaciones
militares con la vecina colombia por
orden del presidente nicolás maduro
entretanto el mandatario colombiano
gustavo petro aseguró que hay
acercamientos pero descartó rumores de
un encuentro con maduro
nuevos problemas para el presidente
pedro castillo un grupo de legisladores
busca sacarlo del poder e inhabilitarlo
acusándolo de traición a la patria al
querer ceder parte del territorio
peruano para darle una salida al mar a
bolivia tenemos reportes desde el libro
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz comenzamos en cuba
porque ya empiezan a ceder las llamas
del incendio que destruyó el 40 por
ciento de la principal instalación de
almacenamiento de combustible en la
región de matanzas de acuerdo con la
presidencia del país y medios oficiales
el fuego se encuentra en un estado más
favorable aunque aún es de grandes
proporciones el incendio que inició el
viernes luego del impacto de un rayo
colapsó cuatro tanques de petróleo y las
autoridades tratan de proteger la
batería de otros depósitos que se
encuentran a sólo 150 metros de
distancia para evitar que se extienda la
conflagración no hemos podido acceder
todavía al área de impacto por las
condiciones ahí hay combustión entonces
nosotros no podemos arriesgar nuestra
vida
por ahora cuando puede aumentar vamos a
entrar a través de a tratar de traer la
víctima que están atrapada
el ministro de defensa de venezuela
vladimir padrino lópez informó que
buscará restablecer las relaciones
militares con la vecina colombia por
orden de nicolás maduro entretanto el
presidente d el país gustavo petro
aseguró que hay acercamientos con el
vecino o la vecina venezuela para llegar
a una normalización de las relaciones un
proceso que podría tomar unos dos meses
aproximadamente según el mandatario pero
también descartó los rumores de un
posible encuentro con nicolás maduro
este fin de semana en bogotá
yo creo que en dos meses podemos estar
con lo con lo más importante superado
hay temas más complejos por ejemplo
monómeros colombo venezolanos que donde
se hacían los fertilizantes es una
empresa afectada casi que quebrada
que hay que ver técnicamente cómo se
puede reiniciar hay que ver las formas
jurídicas
hay que ver el sistema de sanciones
que aún está vigente vamos hasta perú un
grupo de legisladores quiere que el
presidente pedro castillo sea denunciado
por traición a la patria pues lo señalan
de sugerir que podría darle una salida
al mar a bolivia un nuevo escándalo en
la política peruana y en medio de las
investigaciones abiertas contra el
mandatario desde el hima nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías con los
detalles el informe señala que el
presidente pedro casi o habría violado
cinco artículos de la constitución
política peruana en especial el artículo
54 que establece que el territorio
peruano es inalienable e inviolable se
argumenta que pedro castillo habría
excedido su uso de poder como presidente
para ofrecer una salida al mar a bolivia
el reporte del
parlamento afirma que el presidente
pedro castillo sería presunto autor del
delito de traición a la patria que es
sancionado por el artículo 325 del
código penal peruano que siguen los
intentos por rescatar a los diez mineros
mexicanos que quedaron atrapados en una
mina de carbón de coahuila la semana
pasada y que se inundó tras un derrumbe
durante los trabajos de excavación según
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador los equipos de emergencia podían
ingresar a la mina esta semana mientras
continúan las labores de drenaje ya que
la profundidad del agua aún es demasiado
alta un dron submarino también será
utilizado para revisar el interior del
socavón
te siguen
y avanzando
ya podemos
y pensar que mañana pasado mañana
ya el tirante de agua va a ser de un
metro y medio y ya van a poder entrar
buzos y rescatistas y otra situación
similar se vivía en república dominicana
las autoridades lograron rescatar ilesos
a dos mineros que habían permanecido
diez días atrapados en un yacimiento de
cobre y zinc más de 100 expertos
hicieron parte del rescate en la mina
ubicada en el cerro de maimón a unos 80
kilómetros al norte de santo domingo los
dos mineros uno dominicano y otro
colombiano habían quedado sepultados
desde el pasado 31 de julio tras un
deslizamiento de rocas el presidente
luis abinader visitó a los rescatados
pensamos
con buenas condiciones pues en el túnel
ventilación
hidratación alimentación todo entonces
estábamos durmiendo también pues somos
por decirlo así entonces eso hizo que
las tallas nosotros no haya sido puesta
tan mala en el salvador un grupo de
ciudadanos se manifestaron para pedir la
libertad de sus familiares detenidos
durante el régimen de excepción dicho
régimen fue implementado por el
presidente en allí bukele para combatir
a las pandillas conocidas como maras los
manifestantes se concentraron en el
monumento a la constitución en san
salvador la capital en donde solicitaron
el cese de los arrestos arbitrarios y
defendieron la inocencia de sus seres
queridos desde el inicio de la medida de
emergencia el gobierno asegura que ha
capturado a más de 46 mil pandilleros
este martes se conmemoró el día
internacional de los indígenas y la ong
human rights watch publicó un reporte
denunciando que las políticas del
gobierno de jair bolsonaro han dejado a
las comunidades originarias en una
situación de mayor vulnerabilidad
beneficiando las invasiones ilegales a
sus territorios y poniendo en grave
peligro sus derechos humanos sobre las
consecuencias de esta desprotección que
además pesan sobre la selva amazónica
previamente consultamos a césar muñoz
investigador de human rights watch para
américa latina y brasil escuchamos mire
nosotros hemos visto con enorme
preocupación las ppl y las políticas y
declaraciones y el discurso del gobierno
de iago sonar contra los derechos
indígenas que han tenido un impacto real
en esas comunidades hemos visto un
aumento del más del 100 por ciento en el
número de invasiones de estos
territorios
realizadas por por minería ilegal
por madereros por cazadores y un aumento
de la violencia en estos lugares el
informe de human rights watch también
señaló que en el gobierno de bolsonaro
se suspendió la demarcación de los
territorios indígenas y se debilitaron
los órganos que los resguardan césar
muñoz nos aclaró la gravedad de no de
marcar estos territorios ancestrales
mire el gobierno de bolsonaro ha tomado
políticas enormemente perjudiciales para
los pueblos indígenas en brasil y para
el medio ambiente
una de ellas ha sido el debilitamiento
enorme de la agencia que está encargada
de la protección de los derechos
indígenas y eso tenía un impacto sobre
sobre la protección de esos derechos y
una de las funciones de esta agencia se
llama funai es la demarcación de
territorios indígenas no es identificar
estos territorios y
marcar los límites
y al final de ese proceso es dar el
título legal colectivo a estos pueblos
que son los mejores protectores del
bosque amazónico en realidad está
demostrado por estudios por satélite y
lo que el gobierno de bolsonaro ha hecho
es paralizar todos esos procesos no ha
no ha demarcado nada o sea los tres años
que lleva y eso lleva a una inseguridad
jurídica sobre la posición de esa tierra
y en la práctica a un incentivo para que
otras personas se invadan ese territorio
con la expectativa de que lo puedan
registrar a su nombre en el futuro en
otras noticias una de las abogadas del
ex presidente de eeuu donald trump
informó que en la redada de este lunes
amaral ago residencia del magnate en
florida el fbi y se llevó
aproximadamente 12 cajas con documentos
ha trascendido que las autoridades
buscan información clasificada que
presuntamente fue retirada de la casa
blanca y que corresponde a archivos
oficiales de la nación ante las acciones
numerosos dirigentes republicanos
denuncia y abuso de poder de los
demócratas y el propio throne lanzó una
campaña de donaciones en su página web
para luchar contra las acciones legales
que puedan producirse sobre su persona
y finalizamos con información deportiva
porque se jugó el primer partido de la
vuelta de cuartos de final de la copa
libertadores el duelo de equipos
brasileños flamengo venció 1 a 0 a
corinthians y se convirtió en el primer
clasificado a semifinales en la jornada
del miércoles talleres jugará con vélez
y palmeiras se enfrentará a atlético
mineiro hasta que este informativo
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]